what's the deal with airplane
peanuts from fights breaking out on
stage you think I [__] to drunk panel
members throwing props kill Tony has had
plenty of insane moments over the last
10 years and these are the top five
wildest bucket poles of all time
starting off with the show's earliest
recorded meltdown I love got CAU in your
throat Tony what's that you got you
heard
me what's that let me buy some time
before I start calling you uh Spanish M
fly you a settle down in the back
a you're getting scared you signed up
for this scared we're having fun right
you guys are throwing stuff at me I'm
throwing it back relax I don't need to
real they get all up tight all a sudden
they back but excuse me we're like the
nerd what did Jerry son threw it back
what's the
deal can you do a theer what [__] no
damn talk about hack all right that's
straight
up wait a second did you hear my
Christopher walking wait wait did you
guys hear my Christopher walking
impression it was like yes I heard
Christopher walk was It was supposed to
be a joke guys they M cowbell you think
that's my closing bit you had 60 seconds
to tell comedy and that I'm doing 60
seconds on a freaking podcast all right
yeah for people to what that's your what
if they hear it oh no what if they don't
like
it well that is what's going to happen
so so what's going to happen am I going
to quit comedy tomorrow because of it
act like this the end
all all right yeah it didn't end up too
well for you tonight you got you got you
got a little bit nervous oh I'm
heartbroken Tony I guess this is the end
of my comedy career I should just pack
up and leave La cuz you said so can
start
walking your comedy career would have to
start for it to come to an
end all right Tony it'll have to come to
an end I guess oh if that impression is
is as good as your other Impressions I'm
pretty excited that I sound like that
Erica you're pretty much completely
[Applause]
unbearable what did you want feedback
for your shitty impr
all you have saying is that we're just
having fun up here so you didn't really
want when I was coming back you guys you
guys didn't have anything for that you
guys were just not even material you
said yourself that you don't do that on
stage that you can't
do think it's going to end my comedy
career no you're just wasting
everybody's [__] time for [__] [__]
about much dude you think way too much
of this podcast they actually think this
is going to make or break my my career
not we're not saying that you're say so
other people can get on the
stage stage everybody hates can I
[Applause]
my I'm going to quit I'm going to quit
comy I'll show you guys I'm going to be
a big star you see it's going to be a
big star I'm going to be a huge star I'm
going to prove you guys wrong I'm going
to make it I'm going to be somebody
you'll see wow can we just you guys can
we just you're still bombing Eric you're
still bombing can we just get out the
part where
[Applause]
he I I just I want to apologize to Aaron
Marsh
and and Rashid stens and every other
person who actually tries and [__]
wants to be a comic that was terrible
Yik I'm pretty sure he just burned uh at
least 80 Bridges and got a sitcom on
tundo up next is the record for the
longest interview in Kil Tony history
Karen Jones was on stage for 25 minutes
and 34 seconds after being pulled out of
the bucket during episode 6:15 featuring
Theo Von the topics discussed during her
record setting interview ranged from
teaching people how to drunk drive to
Karen storming the capital welcome
welcome welcome how long you been doing
standup comedy this is my first time
ever wow that's really good that's
really good for your first time well I
did have a little bit of an edge uhhuh I
taught at a drunk driving school for
almost 10 years okay and they were a
captive audience you guys seemed a lot
more natural when you laughed they
seemed to be laughing to get their card
sign for
court and what exactly did you teach
again no the best trick I learned I
learned more from the drunk drivers than
they learned from me but I learned that
if you get arrested for the third time I
think it's you know drunk driving laws
are by State and in the state of
California on your third one it's an
automatic felony and you're going to be
in a lot of trouble so they say you've
got to get the cops to beat you up
because it's a weekend and then Monday
you go before the judge that's why when
I drink and drive I do blackface and
then I hit the road this way they they
beat me up but uh my local newspaper ran
a story just before thanks giving
accusing me of being a uh white
supremacist terrorist oh my God and all
of a sudden the interview will last
another 4 and 1/2 minutes oh no I wish
we could be continued I wish we could be
continued I've got to knock this out she
might die before her next time on this
show I got to I got to find out now I'll
read a pamplet but I'm not
gonna commit to anything tonight the
Bakersfield Gazette no the Santa Barbara
independent I shouldn't even say their
name oh yeah but the Santa Barb you just
blew up their website right now by the
way I think I'm the most red story they
had last year explain to us why they
thought you were a white supremacist
well they accused me of leading the
Pledge of Allegiance on the capitol
steps on January
6th
were you there I cannot confirm or
[Applause]
deny
fre freedo oh my
god wow we're meeting a real one here
tonight ladies and
gentlemen holy
[__] Little Texas snow Angel over here a
Californian made that [__] trip holy
[__] you must have been the only person
that flew from the Santa Barbara Airport
to DC on that day so January 6th you fly
there how close do you make it how close
to being inside the capital do you get
and Let Me Wait what the [__] was that
look what the are you seeing this dude
wait a second were you wearing horns
like that right
I would never go in a unpubl place I
would never go in a private office but
you paid taxes for that building no no
it's not that it's that I have been to
the capital multiple times on a weekday
and there has never been any reason not
to go in there was never any anything so
I it is a public building and I would
never go in a restricted area but let me
just say the people that outed me to
this this free news paper they're called
internet slle and they don't have jobs
and they spend their time doing facial
recognition to find us but hold it let
me make my point that I flew and went
through TSA I rsvped to the uh event uh
Bank of America wait you RS hold
stop stop I need a replay on the
field I'm calling for a
replay you said that you RSVP to January
6th
yes this is the most unbelievable we are
at 20 minutes and 15 seconds with this
lady that is about four five six times
as long as your normal interview and to
be honest I'm just getting started with
her no I'm kidding we got to put her
want to put me in prison another fun
fact about Karen her son is named Alex
Jones who was pulled out of the bucket a
few episodes after this but coming in at
number three is an alltime Kil Tony
appearance from The Legend Gary Falcon
back to the bucket we
go all right everybody make some noise
for Gary Falcon everyone Gary Falcon
here we go oh here he comes over here
it's Gary Falcon this Gary Falcon
everybody put your hands together for
Gary
FAL hey
uh what's going
on it's good to be here on the Real
Housewives of
[Applause]
KV
anyway I just got back from the
doctor what is
[Applause]
AIDS
yeah you know what kind of a man you are
how soon you pull your dick out when you
walk up to a
urinal for me it's a block
[Applause]
away thank you for having
me wow
wow oh my
goodness this is our first time ever
having Gary Falcon on this show before
you might be one of the best brand
spanking new comedians we've ever seen
here thank you so much Tony for having
me Tony I love your jacket you would get
Gabe bash at a Coldplay
[Laughter]
concert watch out my goodness guys have
you ever seen anybody quite as make a
debut quite as strong as Gary F
incredible
amazing wow
SC I've never seen a a a missing
children poster that could
talk I've never seen 's
grandfather
whoa
Tony I'm Tony watch out this teddy
bear's got
teeth I didn't know Cody had a
brother I didn't know Santa had
AIDS wow holy
[__] Gary Gary Gary get him
Gary God bless us all
everyone wow I'm not going to take any
more time I love what no you did an
awesome job
Garrett thank you David are are you in a
rush to get back to the uh pickup
basketball game nobody picked you
for yes that's true the Irish Falcon
from a [__] Down syndrome family nice
I grasp at straws thereo this Falcon's
got
talents hey it's it's weird to run into
the guy who hands out the prizes at Dave
and Busters but
[Applause]
um
yes wow it's also impressive to meet um
gandal sponsor thank
[Music]
you
[Applause]
and also the guy next to him House of
back pain Le singer that's great God
bless him good Lord this is really
cutting into your time picking up and
recharging bird scooters isn't
it it's a valid point valid point is it
hard walking around Austin when you're
dressed like a victim or
no I mean is it hard walking around as
the ghost of
Austin Hey listen I'm pretty well known
over at the shelter all
right is it hard sitting next to the
Notre Dame vomiting
Irish holy [__] that's racist that's
racist all right I'm going to go get
drunk these are my friends thank you so
much WoW Gary
Falcon I'm just going to let him do
whatever he wants and at number two is
the first fist fight in Kill Tony
history between Jeremiah Watkins and a
guy tripping on shrooms who was
eventually tossed off stage by Big J
oerson oh [__] it's about to
[__] go down put your hands
together for Kyle long
everybody oh [__] I'm not
drunk
uhoh
this is some of the funniest standup
I've ever
seen it's amazing it's amazing how
alcohol doesn't affect some people so I
did mushrooms
today so anyways
Blockbuster do
you do you remember that [__]
Blockbuster
what the [__] Netflix Netflix is better
than Blockbuster
right
[__] [__] Blockbuster you can suck my
dick
Kyle that's a minute Kyle Kyle Kyle
relax look at me over here wa a minute
look at me over here dude hey Taxi
versus um Uber Uber is awesome you got
to listen start listening stop talking
why don't you listen to
me Kyle to Tony can I just say Blanca
from Street Fighter looks pretty
rough all right [__] you
[__] it's back on let's okay shut the
[__] up dude okay dude all right
bro over here shut up down syndro John
White all right
why don't you uhing Kyle Kyle Kyle Kyle
Kyle Kyle over here okay what's up bro
Kyle we're everything's okay Kyle we're
going to let you go I was saying so how
long you been doing stand what how long
you been doing standup I haven't done a
n months but I [__] been I was going
to go back to it what so what do you do
Kyle H he's a full-time garbage pill
kid Kyle over here Kyle Kyle Kyle Kyle
Kyle whoever's here whoever you can't
let him
don't there you go yeah he's gone wow
Kyle long everybody just some guy
tripping on mushrooms Don't Clap it's
back on the first fight in kilon
history Jeremiah defending his ground I
can say unequivocally I have never been
afraid of anybody with freckles and the
last moment on this list is a moment so
wild that it not only produced multiple
standing ovations from the but Tony
himself called it this might be
literally the greatest bucket pull of
all time all right your final bucket
pool of the night goes by the name of
Heath cordz everybody here we go we're
going to finish it strong 60 seconds
uninterrupted by Heath cordz everyone
here we go here comes
Heath oh [__] okay [__] yes make some
[__] noise for Heath corz
everybody going on
I feel
like I feel like I'm the opposite of a
[Applause]
pedophile I'm 21 years old but on on the
outside I'm just a little
boy and that's because For Me growing Up
puberty was a lot like my father
absent and so I get asked about my age
all the time how old are you how old are
you no I'm not selling you fit all how
old are
[Laughter]
you and it gets annoying having day to
answer this question all the time so
over the years I've started to have fun
with it and I sometimes tell people that
I was never
born and that I have been present
through all of what has been and what
will
be
[Applause]
ticket see I came into existence before
the Earth and stars and I will be here
on the day they fall because I am
agess but yeah old enough to [__] your
[Applause]
mother thank you
guys
holy [__] sir oh my
God I hear this rumor all the time that
this bucket is rigged and then I go one
last bucket B let's see what happens and
this [__] monster comes out this is
unbelievable you are built for this you
are the [__] Lamborghini of comedians
I mean holy [__] wow you're a star
there's nothing that's going to possibly
stop you holy [__] you're really 21 yes
sir how long have you been doing standup
comedy 2 years two years in October my
God you live here in Austin I did I just
moved here a couple months ago and you
did it for standup comedy to be at the
epicenter of stand up oh my god wow wow
and where did you move from Alabama baby
wow Alabama [__] yeah Alabama so all it
takes is a nephew [__] an aunt for
this to
happen oh my god well this is wild so
are you like still growing dude
hopefully fingers crossed man fingers
crossed so like do you have like one of
those things where like you go against
your kitchen wall and like do that [__]
or something like that yeah man I still
got one go it hasn't changed since he
was seven it just got that same every
now and then I'll put on my shoes just
so I feel better about myself get a
couple inches okay so let's talk about
your love life a little bit more here
Heath what's going on with it do do any
women believe you at all whatsoever no
way I gave up on that man I don't deal
with it
anymore you're going to find I mean
you're you're I mean you're about to be
famous as [__] [__] so you're going
to be just fine yeah that
was one of these gold digging [__]
sugar babies is going to [__]
absolutely devour you yeah go ahead Ryan
yeah do do me older men pick up on you
yeah
surprisingly not surpris surprising not
surprisingly at all unfortunately it's
crazy every 10 seconds that goes on I
have seven more questions so like we're
in like a real crazy situation right now
this might be literally the greatest
bucket pull of all
[Music]
time you are such a [__] and you know
what's crazy is that if you came out
here and you bombed it would have been
okay and good too but you are literally
a natural comedian you're completely
present you are in the moment calm cool
collected no sweaty nose no sweaty
[__] it's like you've done this a
billion times so I assume you eat you
eat free at most restaurants and stuff
dude Denny's I can eat for like three
bucks that's awesome dude it's amazing H
do you take the glasses off and just
kind of take off see what you look like
your glass though oh
Dream Weaver you better I believe we can
make
it [__] out of here man this guy's a
[__] stud what is like the official
thing what's the curse that's been
placed on you what is it called The
Curse I have no idea doctors can't
figure out they don't know no I had
shitty doctors dude I have no idea you
never gone to another set of doct he
went to an he was going to Alabama
doctors aka the
dentist AKA they don't have dentists in
Alabama exactly it was the gym
teacher I don't know kid you're [__]
up so you have no idea why this is
happening no dude he's normal looking in
Alabama I know really you know that's
wild and you've never like tried to look
into it yeah not enough time not enough
money I got a baby face that works for
me I'm all set let me tell you an angle
let's found an angle yes you certainly
did you better stay like this cuz if you
build your whole hour around looking
like this and then you grow up normal
you're [__] that would suck two in 3
months yeah he he has the most most
painful most painful Growth Spurt of all
time he just spends three months like
oh Bon just stretches
oh suck
it you are a freak of nature and I want
to see more of you and even though
you've only been doing
it two years I do believe that without a
doubt even though we have a lot of them
here and we have to rotate them in and
fit them in when we can there's no doubt
about it Heath ctis is and has to be the
newest golden ticket winner
[Applause]
on
y has to happen absolutely has to
happen Tony called you maybe the
greatest bucket pole of all time do you
feel any pressure climbing the ranks
this fast is there any negative parts to
winning the golden ticket it's a lot of
pressure yeah it's definitely a lot of
pressure If you're looking for even more
kill Tony content including the rest of
this interview with Heath and an
interview with Hans Kim's New Year's Eve
Challenger Rick Diaz you can find that
on the end screen after this and just a
quick heads up regarding our new joke
World merch all orders placed before
December 10th will arrive by Christmas
day please subscribe and thanks for
watching at joke
world that's it joke
world and it world is wld
D that's a great uh YouTube channel joke
World check it out